on this Wednesday night taking Canada's
pulse during the pandemic people who are
living in urban and suburban areas are
more fearful from mandatory face masks
to whether you get a vaccine our
exclusive poll on Canadian attitudes
Ontario's new rules for in-person visits
to care homes she's still asking why am
I not coming up to see her as the
premier promise is a game to build new
long-term care homes and renovate old
ones new charges the Canadian police
officer and his son accused in the
murder of a suspected Liberian warlord
and a monumental replacement it's an
amazing feeling the new statue
symbolizing hope in an old slave Court
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
it's now well established that wearing a
mask
especially in indoor public places
reduces the risk of spreading koban 19
and tonight we have a sense of what
Canadians think about it according to a
nip sauce poll conducted exclusively for
Global News most Canadians support
making mask wearing mandatory though it
depends where you live and there's an
urban rural divide
80% of urban dwellers say they support
mandatory masks compared to 67% of
Canadians who live in rural areas
Canadians have so far done a good job at
limiting the spread of the virus but
numbers are creeping up in some places
and we only have to look south to see
how bad things can get Abigail Beeman
has our top story on Canadian attitudes
to public health rules masks on during
this couple's grocery shop I mean turns
out they feel the same as most Canadians
new Ipsos polling done for global news
shows 79% support mandatory masks in
public places support is highest in
Manitoba and Saskatchewan at 84% and
lowest in Atlantic Canada just 64
percent
I think everybody's feeling safe because
of how easy we've had it compared to you
know America or some of the other parts
of Canada people who are living in urban
and suburban areas are more fearful and
are more desirous of things like wearing
masks or or potentially closing down
again than people who live in rural
areas the virus is still in the
community living in rural Manitoba
virologist Jason kinder Chuck
understands that divide but says
everyone needs to be aware there's still
a risk and he says that risk still
exists outdoors even though if Tso's
found people are far less likely to
leave their masks on outside yes there's
some data to suggest that outdoors
there's less risk but we have to
understand that ultimately we have to
remove that ability of the virus to be
able to transmit and if we put people in
close proximity that's what's going to
happen
close proximity like at this Toronto
restaurant an investigation is now
underway in Montreal Copa 19 test
lineups last hours public help asking
anyone who's been to a bar since July
first to get one there have been at
least 30 cases linked to nine bars I
don't think there's any social
distancing happening and as companies
around the world including Canadian ones
race to create a vaccine to eradicate
cope in nineteen if cells found 72% of
Canadians support making vaccinations
mandatory I think that's the way to go
and that's the reason why we keep saying
and the government keeps saying until a
vaccine until we get a real effective
vaccine we have to continue maintaining
these measures experts we spoke with are
cautiously optimistic we could see a
vaccine in 2021
meanwhile the Ipsos polling shows 77% of
Canadians believe a second wave will hit
their community before then in the fall
Abigale be mimic global news Ottawa
Calgary and Banff are considering making
mask-wearing mandatory and indoor public
spaces as the number of new cases in
Alberta keeps creeping up more than 40%
of the provinces active cases now are in
Calgary the mayor has warned the city
could make masks mandatory in all public
indoor spaces if more Calgarians don't
start wearing them the province is
distributing millions of non-medical
masks and Alberta's chief medical
officer of Health strongly recommends
wearing them in Bath Town Council has
asked for a bylaw to be drafted that
would require visitors to cover their
faces in the downtown area and in
enclosed public spaces the draft bylaw
isn't expected to be brought back to
Council until early August residents in
long-term care homes have endured social
isolation for months now today Ontario
announced limited indoor visits to care
homes with no Co bid 19 cases will be
allowed as of July 22nd there's also a
promise to help beat the sweltering heat
in care homes with no air-conditioning
premier Doug Ford has said the long-term
care system in Ontario is broken and
today he pledged again to spend 1.75
billion dollars to build multiple new
facilities and renovate old ones it's
the same thing he promised two years ago
and didn't
liver and it's led to thousands of
people suffering Karin Lieberman reports
from the sidewalk across the street from
Eatonville care center in Toronto
Michaels wants visits his 93 year old
mother she's still asking why am I not
coming up to see her the last time they
hugged was four months ago it's tough
it's been tough with the province
relaxing the rules for visits to
long-term care homes
swats may finally be able to see his
mother face to face they're gonna be
outside on the patio which is fine no
matter where you live you and your loved
ones should have access to top-notch
long-term care with that Ontario Premier
Doug Ford reiterated a nearly two
billion dollar investment in the sector
to build new beds and upgrade olds homes
with features like air conditioning the
building's themselves really in many
cases needs significant investment and
we've seen that in things like having
Ward rooms for people in a room divided
by a curtain with shared bathing
facilities sometimes upwards of 20
people using the same bathing but no one
wants to live like that especially
during a pandemic when most of the
provinces collude related deaths have
been linked to nursing homes the
Canadian Armed Forces was deployed to
five long-term care homes with severe
Kovan 19 outbreaks in Ontario in April
and in May the military released a
damning report outlining major issues at
each one of them that's right to you and
me ROS Riley O'Hara's 103 year old
mother is in long-term care
she says the problems are not new
staffing is short-handed where you don't
have the right mix of people and when
old buildings are in focus it gets worse
in Quebec the Chief Coroner ordered a
public inquiry into deaths in long-term
care homes and private seniors
residences we really are needing some
national standards so that each province
and territory can live up to what every
Canadian would want to have for their
older relative for Michael Swanson's
mother who he says survived kovat 19
give her another
package of Oreos it starts with a long
overdue visit Karen Lieberman Global
News Toronto in the United States it's
now clear the lack of public health
restrictions and reopening the economy
too soon is killing people new cases are
surging in multiple states in Florida
it's situation critical more than ten
thousand new positive cases of Kovac 19
were reported today and more than 112
people died as Jackson prosecco reports
it's going to get worse because
intensive care wards are flooded with
sick people
Florida's hospitals are in critical
condition facing wave after wave of
kovat 19 patients stretching I see use
beyond capacity at more than 50
hospitals in the state unless you're as
close to it as we are you really don't
understand how serious it is
Lea Carpenter is both a nurse and a
hospital CEO with her ICU overwhelmed
she has had to convert an auditorium and
classrooms to handle the influx of
patients when you look at there being
ten thousand new cases today 15,000
cases on Saturday do you worry about
what's coming down the pipe absolutely I
worry about it I'm not really convinced
that our numbers are have even reached
what it could be
Florida's reluctance to lock down and
refusal to mandate face masks has come
at a heavy cost more than 300,000 cases
nearly 10,000 hospitalized we still
haven't been out of the first wave and
the cases keep growing they keep growing
nurse Dana James says she's never seen
anything like it she's frustrated by
efforts to downplay the severity of the
pandemic we hear a lot from political
leaders who say well look the the
average age is coming down or the death
rate has stayed low I'm just curious
what your response is to that let's not
just talk about the death rate let's
talk about somebody who's not going to
die but is on a ventilator for months
and months in recent days the state's
death rate has set new records along
with the daily number of new cases
despite the governor blaming young
people for spreading the virus doctors
say the patient
showing up in hospital are increasingly
older in the last couple of weeks we
have seen enormous increase in the
number of patients require mechanical
ventilation that are in their sixties
and seventies similar to what we saw
back in in March this time around there
are far more patients and there's far
less certainty that the virus can be
reined in Florida has vowed not to move
backwards on its reopening the frontline
workers are left to brace for what comes
next what I'm probably most concerned
about is what's to come are we going to
get control of this are we gonna level
it out Jackson prosto Global News
Washington
back in this country the leader of the
bloc québécois
Yves Francois Blodgett is denying a
sexual assault allegation made against
him that dates back more than 20 years
the anonymous accusation which includes
graphic details of the alleged assault
appeared on social media our Mike
Armstrong is looking into this including
why the claim is coming out now Mike
well Donna there's sort of been a wave
of accusations made online and
anonymously in recent days against
several Quebec celebrities and public
figures vache is the first politician
the accusation was posted last evening
on a Facebook group hyenas and skirts
calls itself a feminist collective that
pushes for change through disruption in
it the writer recounts the night of
bar-hopping in 1999 where she ended up
in the bathroom of an after-hours Hells
Angels club with she says Eve press
WebLogic she alleges he groped her tried
to undress her offered her cocaine in
exchange for oral sex and then
masturbated in front of her the bloc
québécois issued a statement this
morning responding to the post
it says Blanchette quote unequivocally
denies the alleged acts and invites the
person who published the allegations to
file a complaint to the proper
authorities the 55 year old blonde has
been the leader of the bloc since
January of last year prior to that he
was in provincial politics as well at
the time of the allegations 21 years ago
he was a music promoter he was managing
one of Quebec's biggest stars and at
that point the Facebook allegations say
Lapointe was there the night in question
Global News has reached out to both
Lapointe and the person who posted the
message the claims have not been
verified
as to why she waited so long she says
she kept it bottled up for years until
yesterday when she realized who blush it
was and that he was in politics Donna
Mike Armstrong in Montreal some of the
world's wealthiest people and
corporations have been targeted in a
massive and brazen cyberattack hackers
took over dozens of Twitter accounts
including those of Apple uber
billionaires Bill Gates Jeff Bezos and
Elon Musk as well as former US President
Barack Obama and current presidential
candidate Joe Biden their accounts were
used to post Bitcoin scams tricking
people into sending more than 200 money
transfers adding up to $100,000 the
tweets were up for only a few minutes
and Twitter says it is investigating a
heartbroken mother and father consumed
by grief will never stop fighting for
you coming up the message from the
parents of regis court schinsky pac
heads
a judge in Minnesota has allowed the
media to view police body cam video of
the final moments of George Floyd's life
though news organizations are not
allowed to publish it those who have
seen it say it shows Floyd pleading with
the officers in the minutes before his
death telling them he's not a bad guy as
they try to wrestle him into a squad car
a few minutes later Floyd is face down
on the street with Derek Shogun's knee
on his neck for almost nine minutes the
video confirms Floyd's last words were I
can't breathe today Floyd's family filed
a civil lawsuit against the city of
Minneapolis and the four police officers
charged in his death
the wrongful death suit cites a lack of
proper police training and a culture of
racism with bad behavior within the
department the city of Minneapolis has a
history of policies and procedures and
deliberate indifference when it comes to
the treatment of arrestees especially
black men
lawyers for Floyd's family say the
lawsuit seeks to set a precedent that
makes it financially prohibitive for
police to wrongfully kill marginalized
people especially black people in the
future there is an update tonight into
the investigation of the death of regis
court schinsky Paquette the young black
woman who fell from the balcony of her
Toronto apartment building lawyers for
her family say the Special
Investigations Unit is now in the
closing stages of its investigation and
a second autopsy is being done outside
Ontario the 29 year old woman fell from
her family's 24th floor apartment
building on May 27th before it happened
the family had called police and
officers were in the apartment when she
fell the exact circumstances surrounding
in the final moments leading up to court
schinsky poquette's fall have not been
released today her mother and father
shared how they are feeling
just want to talk my daughter I love
them very much
we'll never stop fighting for you till
it di doctor I'm grievin I'm devastated
I'm a little angry that's my daughter on
July 25th a public memorial will be held
in Toronto followed by the first annual
Walk for justice in her name
still ahead the man now charged in the
murder of a suspected Liberian war
criminal in Ontario
a man named Bill Horace lived in Canada
for 18 years until he was murdered in
London Ontario three weeks ago one of
his alleged killers has now been
arrested and charged with second degree
murder and the victims past has caught
the attention of the international
community as Mike Jolie reports Horace
is alleged to have been a notorious
warlord accused of terrible crimes in
Liberia one of Canada's most wanted is
now in police custody
Kieran Gregory is alleged to have
murdered a man in a home invasion in
London Ontario
Gregory's father Toronto Police Officer
Trevor Gregory was also arrested for
breach of trust it was a shocking crime
on a quiet street that immediately
gained international attention because
of the identity of the victim 44 year
old Bill Horace an alleged Liberian war
criminal police believe his murder is
related to business dealings in Canada
not his alleged past which journalist
Michael Petro exposed in a 2010 McLean's
article some of the allegations made
against mr. Horace involved murder
involved sexual violence some of which
was of a nature that a I am I editors
didn't feel comfortable committing to
print so how was the man known as
general bill allowed to stay in Canada
much less enter it in the first place
his dossier in the Canadian court system
is extensive
Horace arrived in Canada in 2002 and was
given a departure order but he appealed
and in 2005 was found in admissible
because of war crimes he filed in lost
appeals in 2008 in 2009 before
attempting to stay on humanitarian
grounds again he lost but didn't leave
in 2015 he asked the courts to order the
government to give him permanent
residence that too was denied and Horace
was in the process this year of trying
again what is clear from court documents
is that Canadian authorities didn't
believe his claim that he was a chaplain
when he arrived as a refugee 18 years
ago once the guy was in the system the
system did identify him so a that worked
he was ordered to remain
yet was never removed a quarter million
people died in the brutal 1990s conflict
has an ability has tried to bring the
perpetrator to justice and says he
collected witnesses to Horace's alleged
crimes which he gave to canadian war
crimes investigators in hopes Horace
would be deported I was just shocked you
know I had my mouth wide open and I was
Jenna that come on I may be king of
human way justice come on
Canada ability says many in Liberia were
sad to hear about Horace's death because
he says they wanted justice where his
alleged crimes were committed microlight
Global News Toronto you can read more
about Bill Horace and the charges
against the man accused of killing him
on our website Global News CA / global
national Mexico wants the Canadian
government to extradite a former
investigator involved in the case of a
group of missing indigenous students who
are believed to have been murdered
Tomasz aaron is accused of manipulating
the probe into the disappearances and
tampering with evidence Mexican
authorities say he's now in Canada they
met with Canadian officials this week to
discuss the extradition request Canada's
Department of Justice told Global News
it could not comment on the request
until it's made public by the courts in
2014 43 students were travelling back
from a protest when they were seized by
local police then allegedly turned over
to a drug gang and killed the original
investigation concluded their bodies
were burned at a garbage dump but that
claim has been discredited a new clue
emerged last week with the
identification of a bone fragment found
in a ravine we have much more about the
case of Tomas Zarin on our website
Global News za / global national next
the statue swap in England with a
monumental message
the black lives matter movement has led
to a rethink all over the world about
the people we choose to commemorate
statues of men once held in high esteem
are being toppled in lots of places
including in the UK today in Bristol
England a new statue replaced an
original one and as Redmond Shannon
reports the mayor says it must come down
but locals seem to approve of it a fist
raised height the Black Power salute
over this former slave port this new
installation replaces the statue of
slave trader Edward Colston his ships
transported 80,000 people into slavery
in the Americas it stood here for 125
years until protesters tore it down last
month and threw it into the harbour and
it was on that day that activists again
read climbed the plinth and inspired a
local artist Marc Quinn to me that was
immediately crystallize into into
sculpture and I thought perhaps this
brilliant moment that she created
herself could be crystallized and how
apt is that here in the home of Banksy
but the statue was installed early on
Wednesday morning without the permission
of the city it's an amazing feeling it's
really exciting we'd worked with Queen
over the past month to make it happen
he's really captured it so well you know
for me getting on that plant
you know I raised my fist and I raised
my fist to give power back to the people
back to the slaves who died at the hands
of Colston I gave power to George Floyd
Richard Powell has lived in Bristol all
his life he came down to witness what he
calls a piece of history for some people
it all be quite objective but I think
the majority as we demonstrated with
taking out that previous statue that
most people in this city would agree
that things have to change
Quinn says he will not be a permanent
installation but if enough Bristol Ian's
continue to sing its praises
Reed's salute could stand here for some
time to come Redman Shannon Global News
Bristol England and that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's your Canada
is this dog taking a stroll near winkler
the largest city in Manitoba's Pembina
Valley lovely scene we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to us and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]